- It's a hillbilly way of saying
back that thing up, or bootylicious.
(intense guitar music)
(funky electronic music)
- Should be interesting.
- Probably about trucks and beer.
- Hopefully they're not
too against country.
Well, let's see what we got here.
- Buzzfeed, take one.
- Does every great country
star grow up on a farm?
No.
- No. That's so funny!
- I didn't grow up on a
farm, so yes, so maybe yes.
- I grew up in southern California.
Country music spans the whole globe,
and it could come from anywhere.
- What does Honky Tonk Badonkadonk mean?
Well, this is somebody
that knows country music.
- Booty!
♫ Honky tonk badonkadonk.
- A well-proportioned butt.
- Is there a single dirt road ...
(laughing)
- Is there a single dirt
road every country star
has to visit before writing a song?
- That is a great question.
Yes, there's this one specific
dirt road in Nashville.
It's about two miles south of town.
- No, any old dirt road will do.
- You sing a lot about
being down by the river.
Is it better than being down by the beach?
- The river is pretty fun, especially
when you're younger and
you don't live by a beach.
- I am from Florida, so
I have many more songs
about being by the beach
than I do being by the river.
- Why does every country
song have to mention
a tractor, beer, boots,
or kicking up the hay?
What the hell are you listening to?
- See, that's what people think!
- I'm sure I'm wrong, but I've never heard
the expression "kicking up the hay."
- There's a lot of songs
about tractors, beer, boots.
Those are great songs too.
There's actually more to it than that.
- Somebody needs to die,
somebody needs to get laid,
and you gotta say
something about your mama.
Those are things that are
in every country song.
- Why whiskey?
- Why not?
- Because whiskey is awesome.
- Like if it gives you that
weird warm feeling inside.
- Hey man, we're gonna go out there, man,
hit the old pinot noir, and
do a little two steppin'.
It just doesn't sound right, does it?
- Does Jesus always
have to take the wheel?
- Well, I sure hope he does if
I start to have an accident.
- Well, if he's in your life ...
- Yeah, and if you've been drinking ...
- I'd rather have Jesus take
the wheel than anybody I know.
- Does Jesus always
have to take the wheel?
No, that's up to you.
- Do any of your songs mention a cat
or are you really all just dog people?
- Oh, I could answer that so many ways.
- I am a dog person.
- You don't think of a cat
being loyal and wonderful.
Dogs are very loyal creatures.
- And I just don't like cats,
so I can't speak for the
rest of country music.
- All you non-country fans out there,
I guess that's like maybe two of you.
- We're a good blend of
everything right now.
I pull from all the top 40 hip hop songs,
pull from all the classic rock stuff.
- We aren't all singing
about picking up chicks
and putting them in the truck bed.
I don't really think it would
make sense for me to do that.
- If you like lyrics about real people
and real situations, maybe
you should listen to it.
- I found country music because
I had an older sister who hated it.
One day, trying to be an
annoying little brother,
I turned it on and Tim
McGraw "Don't Take the Girl"
came on, and I fell in
love with country music.
I don't know what the natural
inclination to push back
against country music
is, but it's timeless
and it's not going
away, so give it a shot.
- Those were funny questions actually.
I actually have those same questions.
(bubbly music)